bonsoir claude blanchemaison merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
à leur première question pourquoi
l'armée at-elle perpétuer perpétrés par
dont un coup d'état
l'armée n'a pas accepté le résultat des
élections législatives du mois de
novembre dernier
c'est le parti de mahmoud sookie qui les
a très largement gagné et l'armée qui ne
pouvait pas accepter ce résultat a dit
qu'il y avait eu des fraudes s'est
retourné vers la commission électorale
qui a confirmé le résultat des élections
est en effet comme vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure dans votre sujet ce nouveau
parlement devait se réunir aujourd'hui
il y avait donc urgence pour les
militaires à agir d'autant plus que ce
nouveau parlement devait élire d'ici le
mois de mars un nouveau président de la
république et que le parti de madame
aung san suu kyi avait bien attention dû
faire discuter de réformes
constitutionnelles
les réformes constitutionnelles
porterait sur les privilèges dont
bénéficient les militaires puisque dans
le début de la transition ce sont les
militaires qui ont écrit la constitution
en 2008 et 7 en vertu de cette
constitution qu'ils détiennent 25% des
sièges dans chacune des deux assemblées
et que c'est peut-être au stade actuel
de l'évolution
c'était peut-être en effet un vestige du
passé de la même façon que leur contrôle
absolu du ministère des armées du
ministère de l'intérieur et les
frontières sans avoir à rendre compte au
gouvernement
donc en plus il était très inquiet de
développement de la lutte contre la
corruption que madame aung san suu kyi
avait engagé et santé certains de leurs
intérêts menacés par ailleurs ils ont
sans doute choisir cette époque parce
que il est vrai que l'aura de madame
aung san suu kyi avait un peu pâli
lorsqu'elle avait elle n'avait pas pris
la défense des rings à l'héroïne gacé
cette minorité musulmane qui a été très
mal traités et chassé de son territoire
ils sont maintenant réfugiés un peu
partout mais notamment au bangladesh est
maintenant au tour ce qui avait même été
défendre la position officielle du
gouvernement birman à la cour de justice
ce internationale allait probablement
les militaires ont fait une erreur de
calcul
ils ont crié ils ont cru que les toiles
de valence ou qui avaient un peu pâli en
vérité tous les pays occidentaux
naturellement prennent aujourd'hui sa
défense est-ce que clairement trop
blanche maison on peut dire que c'est un
coup porté au processus démocratique en
birmanie
oui bien sûr puisque c'était un
processus comme vous le comme vous le
dites il était engagé et qui devait se
poursuivre la participation
les sièges réservés aux militaires dans
les assemblées étaient quelque chose de
provisoire
le fait que des ministères échapper au
contrôle du gouvernement était aussi
provisoire par conséquent la réforme
devait se poursuivre or là les
militaires procèdent à un retour en
arrière en décrétant l'état d'urgence en
suspendant le parlement est probablement
pendant cette année d'état d'urgence
ils vont essayer d'élaborer une des
textes qui garantissent les privilèges
dont ils bénéficient actuellement ils
veulent continuer à contrôler
l'essentiel de l'activité
gouvernementale
en tout cas en ce qui concerne la loi et
l'ordre en ce qui concerne la sécurité
extérieure
et en ce qui concerne les frontières
alors c'est très ennuyeux pour le pays
parce que lorsque le processus de
libéralisation avait commencé les pays
occidentaux pour l'encourager avait levé
les sanctions économiques et il ya donc
des investissements qui se sont faits en
birmanie et qui aujourd'hui risquent
d'être remis en question alors pékin et
les autres voisins de la birmanie appel
à régler ce différend quels sont les
enjeux pour ces pays là la chine et la
grande base in c'est le principal
partenaire économique et la chine
construit beaucoup d'infrastructures en
birmanie elle construit un corridor pour
relier le territoire chinois à l'océan
indien la même façon qu'elle le fait
beaucoup plus à l'ouest de l'autre côté
de l'inde au pakistan est donc pour elle
l'essentiel c'est que le calme règne
dans le pays et qu' il n'y ait pas de
guerre civile naturellement dans ce pays
c'est pour elle le point essentiel mais
elle a appelé aujourd'hui à ce que les
différents soit résolu suivant les
termes de la constitution c'est-à-dire
en fait suivant les termes que
souhaitent les militaires faisant
peut-être abstraction du résultat des
élections législatives du mois de
novembre pour les autres pays d'asie
l'inde est embarrassée parce qu' elle ne
veut pas laisser la birmanie tomber
complètement dans le giron de la chine
d'ailleurs elle avait promis il ya
quinze jours d'envoyer un ou deux
millions de doses de vaccins que vite
vaccin de vaccins indien robert mans et
elle va le faire certainement la chine
va évidemment en envoyer au temps où un
peu plus que ce qui est vraie rivalité
entre ces deux pays pour influencer la
birmanie pour le reste la birmanie est
un des dix pays d'asie du sud est qui
fait partie de ce groupement des pays
d'asie chine est ce qu'on appelle la zad
et qui est un groupement qui est surtout
intéressé par en faire une zone de paix
en utilisant notamment les échanges
économiques
le libre échange et dans les pays de la
zale on a pour habitude de ne pas
critiquer le régime politique du voisin
d'autant plus que les régimes politiques
sont très différents il ya à l'intérieur
et zean de régime communiste le vietnam
et le laos un régime à parti dominant
trail dominant le cambodge un pays qui a
connu un coup d'état militaire et dont
ils se sauvent ce coup d'état militaire
continue à produire ces résultats c'est
la thaïlande
et puis d'autres pays qui ont des
élections et qui sont plus démocratiques
comme la malaisie comme les philippines
ou comme ou com
il ya aussi par exemple pardon j'avais
oublié le sultanat de brunei il lui
évidemment est un régime
tout à fait autoritaire donc à l'asian
on ne critique pas le régime des voisins
et il est probable que l'adn sera
surtout intéressés par le fait qu' on
trouve une solution pacifique à la crise
actuelle et que ça ne dégénère pas en
guerre civile
merci claude blanche maison pour votre
analyse